[Music]
he was a powerful king whose break with
the Church of Rome would forever change
the course of English history but was he
a charismatic reformer or a bullying
tyrant find out on history versus Henry
the eighth looks like quite the dashing
fellow indeed your honor this is Henry
the eighth the acclaimed king who
reformed England's religion and
government and set it on coast to
becoming a modern nation I beg to differ
this is a cruel impulsive and
extravagant king who had as little
regard for his people as he did for his
six wives six wives your honor Henry's
first marriage was arranged for him when
he was only a child he only married
Catherine of Aragon to strengthen
England's alliance with Spain and
alliance he was willing to toss aside
with no regard for the nation
Henry had every regard for the nation it
was imperative to secure the Tudor
dynasty by producing a male heir
something Catherine failed to do in over
20 years of marriage it takes two to
make an heir your honor
hit him regardless England needed a new
queen to ensure stability but the Pope
refused to annul the Union and let the
King remarry sounds like quite a pickle
can't argue with the Pope and yet that's
exactly what the king decided to do he
uprooted the country's religious
foundations and broke the Church of
England away from Rome leading to
centuries of strife all Henry did was
give the church honest domestic
leadership he freed his subjects from
the corrupt Roman Catholic establishment
and by rejecting the more radical
changes of the Protestant Reformation he
allowed his people to preserve most of
their religious traditions objection the
church had been a beloved and popular
institution that brought comfort and
charity to the masses thanks to Henry
church property was seized hospitals
closed and precious monastic libraries
lost forever all to enrich the crown
some of the funds were used to build new
cathedrals and open secular schools and
it was necessary for England to bring
its affairs under its own control rather
than Rome's
you mean under Henry's control not true
all of the king's major reforms went
through Parliament
no other country of the time allowed its
people such as say in government he used
Parliament as a rubber stamp for his own
personal will meanwhile he ruled like a
tyrant executing those he suspected of
disloyalty among his victims were the
great statesman and philosopher Thomas
More once his close friend and advisor
and Anne Boleyn
the new queen Henry had torn the country
apart to marry he executed his own wife
that wasn't King Henry's initiative she
was accused of treason in a power
struggle with the Kings Minister Thomas
Cromwell the trial was a sham and she
wouldn't have been convicted without
Henry's approval besides he wasn't too
upset by the outcome he married Jane
Seymour just 11 days later a marriage
that a note succeeded in producing a
male heir and guaranteeing a stable
succession though the new Queen
tragically died in childbirth this
tragedy didn't deter him from an
ill-conceived fourth marriage to Anne of
Cleves which Henry then annulled on a
whim and used as an excuse to execute
Cromwell as if that weren't enough he
then married Katherine Howard a cousin
of Anne Boleyn before having her
executed too she was engaged in adultery
to which she confessed regards final
marriage to Katherine Parr was actually
a very successful his sixth it only goes
to show he was an intemperate king who
allowed faction and intrigue to rule his
court concerned only with his own
pleasure and grandiosity that
grandiosity was part of the king's role
as a model for his people he was a
learned scholar and musician who
generously patronized the Arts as well
as being an imposing warrior and
sportsman and the lavish tournaments
have hosted enhanced aliens
the state and yet both his foreign and
domestic policies were a disaster his
campaigns in France and his brutal
invasion of Scotland drained the
treasury and his attempt to pay for it
by debasing the coinage led to constant
inflation the lords and landowners
responded by removing access to common
pastures and turning the peasant
population into beggars beggars who
would soon become yeoman farmers the
enclosures made farm and more efficient
and created a labor surplus that laid
the foundation for the Industrial
Revolution England would never have
become the great power that it did
without them and without Henry well I
think no matter what we can all agree he
looks great in that portrait a devout
believer who broke with the church a man
of learning who executed scholars a king
who brought stability to the throne but
used it to promote his own glory Henry
the eighth embodied all the
contradictions of monarchy on the verge
of the modern era but separating the
ruler from the myth is all part of
putting history on trial check out more
videos in our history verses series to
see how some of the world's most
controversial leaders wielded their
power
[Music]